from the earliest footage of a young
Princess Elizabeth with the Queen Mother
to a teenager dancing alongside her
sister and together with her mother and
governess Marion Crawford on board a
yacht then as mother with her children
locking about in the back gardens of
Buckingham Palace with Prince Phillip
home videos of young Royals growing up
never before released but in the year
Prince George celebrates his first
birthday this previously unseen footage
along with a hundred and fifty items
charting the early years of 25 royal
children will be available to all at
Buckingham Palace from this weekend like
William and Harry's nursery chairs the
Queen's childhood cupboard door with the
shoes of her first horses nailed into it
Prince William's pageboy outfit made for
the Duke and Duchess of York sweating
the Duke of Cambridge's geography
exercise book indicating early signs of
an interest in conservation and early
works from a budding nine-year old
artist Prince Charles as well as his
building blocks being played with in
this footage the film footage really
shows these objects being used so for
example we see Princess Anne riding a
red tricycle around the grounds of
Buckingham Palace and we also see at the
same red tricycle being ridden by the
Duke of Edinburgh
so it shows families playing just as
regular families would there are gifts
on show to marking the birth of Prince
George this rocking horse are present
from President Obama and his wife this
Boris trike from the Mayor of London
both yet to be used by the one year old
it's perhaps not every little boy and
girl who gets presented with one of
these a miniature Caravan given to
Prince Charles and Princess Anne by the
Caravan Club complete with its grille
it's sink its curtains and cushions and
who harbored desires of a jet-set
lifestyle of James Bond the db5 Aston
Martin was Prince Andrews of course not
half as fun as an orange tractor Prince
Charles might argue Paul Harrison Sky
News Buckingham Palace
you